la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue caroline cayeux pour le groupe
l'est républicain
vous avez la parole ma chère collègue
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur vidal east ministre chargé des
transports de la mer et de la pêche
monsieur le ministre permettez moi de
m'exprimer en tant qu'élu des
territoires comme vous tous mes chers
collègues et plus particulièrement
françois commeinhes sénateur de
l'hérault mais aussi en tant que
président de l'association villes de
france sur le sujet capital pour nos
collectivités comme pour nos administrés
des trains d'équilibré du territoire ou
les trains intercités le ferroviaire
régional et inter régionale joue
effectivement un rôle majeur non
seulement dans la mobilité des personnes
sur le territoire national mais aussi
sur les déplacements des actifs et aussi
des étudiants souvent pour leur
formation
la pérennité de ces trains d'équilibré
du territoire semble condamnée à l'issue
de l'étude dans le cadre de la
commission durant ce rapport préconise
en effet fermeture de lignes allègement
d'un certain nombre de dessertes je
pense à la liaison bordeaux nice alors
que la démographie des territoires
traversés et souvent positives
cette offre devait être propres et
dément revue essentiellement par la
substitution d'autocars le transfert aux
régions où la cessation de ces lignes
les élus des territoires que nous
représentons estimons premièrement qu'il
ne peut pas y avoir de démembrement sans
un débat préalable devant la
représentation nationale
deuxièmement en raison de l'abandon
programmé par l'état du principe de
conventionnement de ce service public
nous demandons une ouverture rapide de
l'offre d'exploitation à la concurrence
de toutes les lignes concernées dans des
conditions de transparence renforcée
nous dénonçons également le tout tgv
logique privilégiant un polycentrisme
parisien et allant à l'encontre d'un
aménagement équilibré du territoire
quant au remplacement de ses trains par
des services d'autocars à l'heure où la
france se prépare
à accueillir la conférence sur le climat
au mois de décembre cela nous semble
aller à l'encontre des principes
essentiels du développement durable
monsieur le ministre l'état s'apprêtent
ils oui ou non demain à renoncer à un
outil efficace pour maintenir un
maillage cohérent de nos territoires
monsieur le ministre pouvez vous nous
dire si vous confirmer ces annonces
et si les intentions du gouvernement à
la matière était avérée de bien vouloir
par respect pour les élus et les
populations qui vivent sur ces
territoires y surseoir pourront répondre
la parole et au secrétaire d'état aux
transports vous avez la parole monsieur
le ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice la situation qui est évoqué
par le rapport qui met un été qui a été
remis au gouvernement est le résultat
d'une convention qui a été passé en 2010
le constat c'est que la question du
déficit financier n'a pas été examinée
en 2010 que le matériel qui a
aujourd'hui 33 ans il avait déjà trente
ans que personne s'en est soucié et que
malheureusement et voudrait bien partir
de là sans que j'insiste trop partager
le fardeau avec moi à partir de là il ya
aujourd'hui une situation d'urgence
jamais contrairement ce que vous avez
dit le gouvernement n'a annoncé et je
m'inscris en faux qu'il allait procéder
à un des conventionnements ça n'est pas
juste le gouvernement qui est chargée
qui autorités organisatrices entend
effectivement dans un nouveau cadre
parvenir à la signature d'une nouvelle
convention
le constat si on veut regarder dans le
détail c'est très hétérogène mais ces
lignes sont déficitaires pas toutes
certaines leçons d'une manière
acceptable
certaines lignes on a un déficit qui est
de 5 euros par voyageur et par jour
c'est pas réjouissant mais il ya une
mission ou de service public qui
rentrent qu'elle remplit certaines
lignes annonce un déficit de 275 euros
par jour et par voyageur est ce qu un
élu responsable et j'ai envie de dire ce
qui souvent nous rappelle à l'exigence
de la maîtrise de la dépense publique
pourrait peut-être prendre un peu aussi
en considération cet aspect de la
problématique 275 euros par jour et par
voyageur c'est une vraie question et on
essaye d'y répondre
ce rapport n'engage pas le gouvernement
le parlement a été immédiatement saisie
puisque les commissions compétentes ont
organisé un débat à ma demande sur ce
rapport et je ferai connaître la feuille
de route vous avez eu raison de rappeler
les principes les principes ils seront
essayer de maîtriser le déficit
respecter les territoires et assurer le
droit à la mobilité et j'espère que sur
ces principes ou serait au rendez vous
merci monsieur lui nice